[Music]
on the streets
at the national stadium and elsewhere
across the chatting capital in germany
thousands have come out to show their
support for one man president idris
debbie
the incumbent leader has been in office
since he took power in a coup more than
30 years ago
debbie is now seeking a sixth term and
promising a new future for chadians
together we're going to build an africa
like other continents that shares a long
history a common history with those who
colonized us
and we're going to start this chapter
together with them
during the 1990 coup debbie overthrew
his predecessor isaiah abre
who he had worked for as a military
advisor before their falling out
three years ago chad's parliament
approved a new constitution that
expanded debbie's powers
it also allowed him to stay in office
until at least 2033
in a vote boycotted by opposition
legislators chad has seen fighting with
rebels in the east
and several attempted coups in recent
years while incumbent president idris
debbie met his supporters on the final
day of the election rally
opposition candidates were notably
absent in the weeks leading up to the
elections
hundreds of chadians protested against
debbie's candidacy
and human rights watch says security
forces have ruthlessly crackdown on
protesters
and opposition parties ahead of the vote
weeks before the elections the army
raided the house of opposition leader
yaya dilo killing two of his family
members
dilo whose candidacy has been rejected
by the high court
along with six others has fled other
opposition candidates have withdrawn
their candidacy
accusing debbie and the military of
intimidation the national
commission election same thing
more more than 50 percent of family
members
if they are not in the party they are
friends of the party so we we see but
this is not a good election this
election will not be
transparent it will be sincere
it will not be
very very free 7.3 million voters have
registered according to chad's national
electoral commission
five other candidates are also in the
race but opposition leaders have called
on their supporters to stay away from
the voting
but those who back the president like
yasir mahadi say they will take part
i will vote because it's my right and
duty i want stability and security as
well as better economy
and i believe the current president is
the man who can provide that
so i will vote others say they'll follow
the lead of the opposition
these are not elections there are no
competitors some have been rejected some
have been intimidated
and things have been the same for the
past 30 years and i don't think there
will be a chance
so i will be recording the election
the polls are open for a single day but
it will take two weeks before a winner
is announced
but many here at the stadium are
confident the candidate they support
will be the one to lead them for the
next five years
hiba morgan al-jazeera jamaina chad